hey y'all time for the flickers of fear
show and i'm doing kind of a newer movie
but listen to this weird [ __ ] that
happened there's like a whole
ordeal about this okay so a while back
as most of you probably know if you
listen to the show to any great degree
i have a massive massive list of movies
both old and new
that i either want to review alone or
have uh
tom and i do it on one of our matinee or
movie retrospective shows
so i just have this huge so i'm
constantly constantly going through
lists of you know old underrated movies
getting recommendations from you guys
going through
you know various horror blogs lists of
you know best horror movies of the past
year the past 10 years whatever so i
have this huge huge list that i have to
get through
so one movie that i've been hearing a
lot about that came out in 2020
was a movie called nocturne now this
movie
was part of there's a kind of an
anthology
series sort of it's similar to what hulu
is doing with into the dark
um you know where they make a movie like
a horror movie every month
like that has to do with the holiday of
that month that's hulu's thing well
amazon prime
also has something and it's called
welcome to the blum house
and obviously that's jason blum his uh
horror production company
and what they have been what they
started doing was they started doing
four films that come out one a week
every october
so this past october 2020 they had four
movies come out
one of which was nocturne that was the
last one the other ones were called the
lie
black box and evil eye now i guess
they're not
related necessarily but i guess what
they're doing is they're having like a
thematic similarity
because i looked up on the wikipedia
page because i'd heard about that thing
but i didn't really know
much about welcome to the blumhouse or
what it was or anything so i guess the
four
first four movies are supposed to be
based around um
and what the quote was was family and
love as redemptive or destructive
forces and these are going to be kind of
like supernatural thrillers that type of
thing
so nocturne was one of those and i kept
seeing it come
up on you know best movies best horror
movies of 2020 list
so i put it on my list and then you know
obviously i have amazon prime so
last night i was kind of like oh okay
i'll get into it and i'll start watching
it
now the confusion arose i didn't know
much about the movie i
knew that it was about a music student
that's pretty much the extent that
the knowledge that i had previously so i
start watching this movie because i'm
just scrolling through amazon prime like
oh there it is and i started watching it
now as i'm watching it i'm like this
isn't a bad movie but this is really not
what i was expecting i'm like i don't
really know why it's called nocturne
it's not anything to do with music
it was basically about a bunch of
teenagers who are having a graduation
party
and then they do a seance and one of
them gets possessed and there's like a
weird
like a time skip thing kind of reminded
me a little bit of coherence or
something like that where it was all
like shot in
one house and um you could tell it was
low budget but it was actually like
pretty decently done
and so i'm watching it i'm like this
really isn't what i was expecting but
this is okay you know this is an r8
movie
and then i notice that this movie which
is as i said also called nocturne
although i still don't know why uh came
out in 2017.
so then i'm looking through amazon prime
and i'm like oh well i was watching the
wrong one
it was called they just have the same
title so i'm like
okay well i'm really stupid so last
night it ended up that i actually
watched two movies called nocturne just
like right in a row
so one from 2017 and the second one the
blumhouse one from 2020
and i've since like when i watched like
some reviews of it like some other
reviewers said too they were like oh you
know there's another movie on there
called nocturne so don't confuse them
and the funny thing about it was i think
it was austin burke's channel
and he had done a review of it and he
ever pino periodically puts up
you know photos or stills from the
movies and most of the stills were from
the blumhouse movie but then one of the
stills was
from the other 2017 movie and i noticed
that somebody in the comments would be
like uh
what was who was that i don't remember
that in the movie so i had to go on
there and answer that was from the other
one that was called that
so and i'm not saying that the other
nocturne from 2017 it's a
perfectly a decent movie i actually i
didn't like it as
that much when it started out because
the characters were kind of obnoxious
and like unlikable and stuff
but once everything started going into
you know weird like time distortions and
it got kind of trippy and everything
it uh it kind of got better so i had
already been like invested in it so i
was like why not so that's like a decent
movie too
but it's just funny that it was called
the exact same thing so
let's talk about the one that i intended
to watch to start with which is the
2020 blumhouse movie called nocturne
okay now just like everything else this
movie
is gonna be i really liked it i didn't
love it
but i really liked it it's not gonna be
everyone's cup of tea because it's not
it does have a lot of horror elements
and it's real creepy and there's like
supernatural [ __ ] happening in it but
it's not real it's not over the top it's
not real gory
it's a lot of it is kind of like i don't
want to say it's not like already farty
necessarily but there is a lot of
metaphorical stuff going on that helps
if you kind of know
you know what's behind it that's all i'm
going to say about that i'm going to try
not to spoil it too much but as i said
it's really hard to talk about movies
without saying what the plot is saying
things that happen in it
so you know so i'm just like i'm giving
you a warning now i might spoil some
stuff that you didn't want spoiled
if you want to see the movie and you
don't want to know anything about it
because like i said i just went into it
knowing it was about a music student and
that was about it you know so if you
want to go into that too then go watch
it it's on amazon prime right now
and be sure to watch the blumhouse one
although like i said the other one's
perfectly fine too
uh you know and watch that and then come
back and talk about it a little bit so
this movie tells the story
of twin sisters their names are juliet
who is played by sydney sweeney who some
she's been a lot of stuff but i think a
lot of people would recognize her from
a handmaid's tale series and she has a
sister
named violet uh known as v who is played
by madison eisman
who i had seen in a ton of stuff i saw
her in
i think she was in goosebumps too which
is the the hollow
haunted halloween one i think she was in
the
newer jumanji movies she's been in a
bunch of [ __ ] like that so
you know she's very recognizable as well
so these two play twin sisters
and they're both uh classical pianists
and they go to kind of like an arts
high school so they're high school
students now
pretty much from the jump you can tell
that there's sort of um
a little bit of a rivalry between the
two sisters i mean they seem very close
they even call each other woomies like
roommates you know what i mean
because they were twins you know but the
thing about it is that
juliet is kind of the plainer
uh sister and you know just in looks a
bit in personality also she's very
introverted
um you know she's never had a boyfriend
she's you know so she's kind of quiet
and her sister is sort of more outgoing
now
the thing about it though is that juliet
is very very serious about wanting to be
a classical
musician but v
her sister seemingly with not as much
effort
is kind of brilliant so she's the one
that gets all the accolades
she's the one that everybody goes to you
know whenever they have some kind of big
thing to do with the school it's like oh
you know
v's gonna do it because she's just like
this brilliant player
and so i so juliette is kind of like
feeling like
a wallflower or feeling like
overshadowed
by her sister so it so happens that at
this high school
there's this girl who right at the
very beginning of the movie there's like
a really looks like a short scene at the
beginning
where there's a girl in a room playing
her name's moira and she's playing a
violin and there's all this weird like
scratched
like uh you know symbols and stuff like
that on the wall
and she suddenly stops playing and then
jumps uh off a building all like out the
window and off the balcony
so she commits suicide now she was
supposed to she was like the virtuoso at
the school right and so
because she killed herself the school
decides well she was going to be
she was going to give like the lead
performance or whatever at this big
you know shin dig or do that they're
doing and they're like well obviously
she can't do it now
because she's dead so we're going to
have open tryouts again
for you know for the next like lead
performer
so obviously julia gets very very
excited about this and then starts doing
[ __ ] like
she finds this book okay she finds like
this book that belonged to moira
like she sort of steals it but i guess
they were cleaning out moira's um
you know cubby or her mailbox or
whatever and the person cleaning out
like dropped it and she picked it up and
she was like oh score
so she keeps it and she notices that
there are these weird
like medieval kind of things in there
like along with the sheet music
and she notices that as the time goes on
the stuff that's drawn in this notebook
seems to have parallels to what is
happening
to her and she has like weird nightmares
she sees
um you know the moira's ghost a couple
of times like in her dreams and whatnot
and you know and as this is going on
she's also getting more and more
you could say confident you could also
say cocky
um she basically just kind of starts
you know she does something like instead
of doing the piece for the
tryouts that she was going to do she
decides without telling her twin sister
that she's gonna do the same piece as
her
which you know which is pretty shitty so
it's all that kind of stuff happens
and then she starts like kind of going
after the you know the sister's
boyfriend and all this other stuff
so you're led to believe and i i think
this is a movie that
needs two viewings because like i said
there's a lot of metaphorical stuff
going on one of the things that's sort
of at the center of this
and i think the sheet music that's um
in moira's book with that has all the
you know creepy satanic
drawings in it which is like almost like
a six step process
it's something like you know sacrifice
purification
like it all says that kind of stuff and
she's drawing it's almost like tarot
card type of looking stuff
so this piece of music is a piece of
music called uh i think it's called the
devil's trill
by tartini who was a real dude
and the story goes it's almost kind of
like a robert johnson like devil at the
crossroads kind of story but it's like
seven i think it's like 17th century
so apparently this dude was kind of like
he wasn't getting
the accolades that he thought he
deserved and so he was going to commit
suicide but then he had a nightmare
in which the devil came to him and sat
on the edge of his bed
and offered him there's like i will you
know play you the
the most awesome song ever all i need is
one soul
so indeed he did play him this song the
devil in the dream
he wakes up he writes it down and that
indeed was the only
uh was the only piece of music that he
was ever remembered for
and i think he did actually end up
killing himself later on so
knowing that story which they do kind of
relate like
there's a teacher at the school mr cask
i think his name is
and he does actually relate that story
to the girl's parents at one point so
it's not like you're just going and
you're supposed to
you know just expected to know who that
dude is but it it's
parallels juliet story because she is
essentially
she resents her sister because her
sister
seems to be kind of the golden child and
she doesn't
seem to put as much effort maybe or at
least she perceives that
that uh v doesn't put as much effort
into her
practicing or playing that it just comes
easy to her and so juliet like
you know resents that because she feels
like she just works and works and works
and she's just never as good
so she basically goes down a route of
it's like a faustian type story you know
where it's kind of like she
will do anything to not just i mean
yes she says she wants to be great and
stuff like that it's almost like
her main goal is just like to be better
than her sister and have her be
recognized
as being better than her so that's kind
of the setup of the story i don't want
to go too much into it there's a lot of
um there's a lot of lucifer stuff in it
because there's a point where
she sees like a bright yellow light and
there's um
you know this symbol that keeps
recurring that's like on the front of
moira's book and it's kind of carved in
the wall
that i guess is supposed to be like the
morning star you know what i mean
because he's supposed to be
you know lucifer lightbringer that kind
of stuff so as i said it's a very
faustian type story where she seems like
she's trading
her soul you know for greatness you know
and it
obviously it's a horror movie so it
doesn't work out quite the way she uh
intended
but you know but overall um i really
really actually did like this movie i
really like
movies about artists
and about kind of the obsession
particularly musicians and stuff like
that but it's like the
obsession about it um you would probably
like this
it's a little bit like it reminded me uh
somewhat of like black swan the
perfection that netflix movie
uh there was another blumhouse movie
called whiplash which i think was about
a jazz musician
so it's kind of in that sort of area um
so if you liked any of those and you
like movies about musicians or like
obsession or
rivalry or something like that then you
would probably really dig this i did
like
the way it was shot um the acting's
great
uh the way it's shot it's almost kind of
like this real drab
sort of atmosphere like because almost
all of it takes place at this particular
like music
high school and it's all just kind of
like not
not overtly so but it's it's real kind
of like washed out looking and it's
almost kind of like
because that's i guess that's how julia
the main character that's how she feels
she feels like she's kind of dull and
dowdy like next to her amazing sister so
she always feels like she's
like a wallflower but then when she
starts to
essentially make her deal with the devil
through this book
um you know that this former student had
before she committed suicide
she starts seeing the you know these
bright lights and this brightly colored
sort of thing which like i said i guess
that's sort of the impact of lucifer
like coming into her life or whatever
so there's that kind of element to it
too which i thought was like really
interesting uh
really well done so i think the name the
the
person that directed this was named and
i'm not sure if i'm pronouncing this
correctly but uh their name is zoo quark
or quirky i'm not really sure because
there's an e at the end
but apparently this is their first film
and like i said i really enjoyed it i
didn't love it love it um
because i think that i kind of wish it
had gone a little bit more into
the ghosty super naturally stuff and a
little less into
i mean i liked the sibling rivalry issue
but i think the whole thing about her
stealing the boyfriend and stuff that
really
that could have been shortened or
excised or whatever it's like you know
it's not a huge deal
but you know they could have just
trimmed that down a little bit
uh but you know it was all just trying
to tell the story of
how she was basically trying to usurp
her sister or even become her sister i
guess she was trying to do that too
by like taking away everything that was
hers so she could kind of you know get
the accolades she thought were due to
her that her sister
was uh getting so there was that kind of
thing but like i said it's a very minor
criticism
it's you know it's not super
action-packed it's very it's
a very dark like mood piece um so like i
said if you liked the perfection if you
liked
uh black swan you know things like that
it's sort of like that
like in the same vein but yeah i just
you know i really really enjoyed it
from what i've heard i haven't watched
any of the other welcome to the
blumhouse
uh movies the three other ones i've
heard that the one i think it was called
evil eye i've heard that one wasn't very
good that it was almost like a lifetime
movie and i haven't heard that much
about the other two
i guess they're doing four more like
this upcoming october with a different
theme
so i don't know we'll see where because
i like i i really like that idea of them
doing that because
you know like i said i've seen some of
the ones that they did on uh hulu
because they you know
as i mentioned they have a similar thing
called into the dark um where they have
a new horror movie coming out every
month
and um i haven't seen all of those
obviously because it's a lot but you
know
the ones i've seen have actually been
really enjoyable
so we'll see if this is kind of what
they're doing i mean for a blumhouse
movie
this is actually one of the you know one
of the best blumhouse movies i've seen
not that i've seen a ton of those but
you know it had more of an artistic sort
of uh
veneer to it not so much and it and it
is more of a suspense
mystery type thing than outright horror
but it does have a lot of creepy
elements to it so if that sounds like
something that
you would enjoy then by all means go
check it out and
tell me what you thought of it in the
comments as i said it's on amazon prime
like i said be sure you get the welcome
to the blumhouse one and not the other
one
this one came out in 2020 the other one
which is also on amazon prime came out
in 2017
which like i said is also a perfectly
fine movie but it's nothing to do with
this one
so you know don't get them confused but
yeah so that'll do it for this
flickers of fear and i will see you guys
on the next one
bye